لم تقصف الطائرات الإسرائيلية
شمال غزة فحسب، بل جنوب غزة أيضًا
على الرغم من دعوة المسؤولين الإسرائيليين
لمليوني فلسطيني نازح إلى الفرار من
الجنوب، ونظرًا لأن هذه القصف يتم
باستخدام أموال الضرائب التي ندفعها، ربما
ينبغي لنا أن نطرح بعض الأسئلة، على سبيل المثال،
كيف يمكن قصف منطقة مكتظة بالسكان؟  قطاع أرضي
مملوء بالأطفال بنسبة 50%
يشكل دفاعًا عن النفس، فكيف يشكل قصف
المستشفيات والكنائس والمساجد
ومدارس الأمم المتحدة دفاعًا عن النفس حسنًا،
تقول إذا كان مقاتلو حماس يختبئون في
المستشفى ويستخدمون المدنيين كدروع بشرية
حسنًا، دعنا نقول أنهم كذلك، أنت
تجادل في ذلك  تسوية المستشفى بالأرض
وقتل الأطفال حديثي الولادة في حاضناتهم
وأمهاتهم في وحدة العناية المركزة لحديثي الولادة، ومرضى السرطان،
وشخص مصاب بكسر في ساقه، والأطباء
والممرضات، والنساء والأطفال
المختبئين في المستشفى، هذه ليست
جريمة حرب، لأنك ستكون مخطئًا
وفقًا للقانون الدولي.  لكن لماذا
لا يقوم الناس في غزة بتسليم
مقاتلي حماس إلى الإسرائيليين، حسنًا، كيف
تقترح أن يفعلوا ذلك إذا كنت
مراهقًا تعيش في سجن مفتوح
وتتعرض للقصف ليلًا ونهارًا، فلنفترض أن
الشرطة المكسيكية والمكسيكية تدخلت
الباب وداهموا منزلك في أي وقت
أرادوا وأغلقوا الماء
وقطعوا طعامك ماذا ستفعل
معهم لمساعدتهم بينما
تموت، هذا مثل السؤال لماذا
لا يساعد السود الشرطة أو يثقون بها، حسنًا  لكن
بعد 9911 قمنا بقصف أفغانستان
دفاعًا عن النفس، نعم فعلنا ذلك وفعلنا ذلك،
أدخلنا تنظيم القاعدة أو قبضنا على بن لادن،
لا، لم يكن بن لادن موجودًا في
البلد الذي كنا نقصفه،
وقد قبض عليه الرئيس أوباما بعد 10 سنوات في باكستان.
باستخدام القوات الخاصة ومن دون قصف
عشرات الأطفال حتى الموت، قصف
أفغانستان جلب لنا احتلالًا لمدة 20 عامًا،
مما جلب لنا المزيد من الأعداء في
العالم الإسلامي عندما جمعنا الناس
في ساحة المعركة
وسحبناهم إلى سجن غوانتانامو وعندما ألقينا القبض عليهم
حرب غير مبررة ضد العراق مبنية على
أكاذيب إدارة بوش التي
تاجرت بغضبنا ومخاوفنا، لقد
انتفض العالم ضدنا بينما ارتكبنا
التعذيب، لذا مرة أخرى ما هو الهدف من
القصف الشامل على غزة، هل هو العثور على
الأشخاص الذين اختطفهم مسلحو حماس؟
7 أكتوبر، حسنًا، كيف من خلال تسوية
أي مأوى يتخذونه من
القنابل، ألا تخاطر بقتلهم جميعًا عن طريق
قصفهم مع الفلسطينيين فقط
بعض الأسئلة ذات الصلة وثق بي،
فالناس يريدون إجابات ثم
شخص ما أي شخص يعمل بالفعل على حل المشكلة
الحقيقية  المشكلة المتمثلة في
احتلال الضفة الغربية في
قطاع غزة منذ 56 عامًا والذي أثار وسيستمر
في إثارة المقاومة العنيفة وحتى المقاومة العنيفة.